the gorosei are immortal and incredibly
powerful rulers from the void century
that have been ruling the world together
with emu for the last 800 years for one
we know that they haven't aged a day
since the incident of o'hara 20 years
ago they are called the five elder stars
even though some of them are not that
old-looking at all they clearly know
everything about the true history and
what happened during the void century as
we can see when dr clover tries to say
the ancient kingdom's name
and we know that they are the highest
ranking celestial dragons the world
nobles who never leave the red line so
why exactly would they be covered in
scars and carry weapons now if just one
of them decided to go out and have an
adventure that might be an excuse but
all of them the world government has
existed for 800 years so there clearly
never was any reason for celestial
dragons to actually fight themselves
heck even against rock the biggest
threat to the world government we know
of garp had to team up with roger
himself to defeat
immortal however they could be the very
kings who defeated the ancient kingdom
and formed the world government in the
first place they could have actively
fought in the war itself and then kept
control ever since that would also
explain why they look and act completely
normal compared to the other dumbed down
and spoiled celestial dragons who have
probably only had children within their
small group of chosen ones yep i'm
saying there might be some incest
problem going on here i mean look at
this
[Music]
all of them run around with their
spacesuits shielding them from the air
that normal humans breathe while the
gorosei have normal clothes and have no
problem being in the same room with
kainu or even shanks and so all of these
pieces of evidence together strongly
suggests to me that these five men are
the original celestial dragons that
founded the world government with the
help of emu which let's be honest would
also help in keeping the secret rule of
the world secret since they would have
been the only five people who ever knew
the truth since the void century with no
need to pass it all on every generation
and risking exposure but how did they
end up becoming immortal in the first
place how powerful are these five men
actually to casually dismiss someone
like a kaino and be in the same room as
one of the yonko without guards and will
the marines ultimately rebel against
them what's up my name is manu and even
though i might not look like it i'm
actually very interested in politics and
history learning about how we got where
we are today and how societies thrive or
fail under different political systems
and i think in terms of one piece it
doesn't get much more political than
when talking about the five elders who
run and govern the entire planets in
fact what i find absolutely fascinating
is that if you only have a vague idea of
what one piece is actually about you'd
probably be absolutely taken aback just
how much politics is actually hidden
under the classic layers of a shonen
manga
not only do we encounter different
political systems and structures with
every new island we visit but as the
story progresses we learn more and more
about the workings of a political
organization that rules the entire world
which now that i think about it is
actually pretty damn hilarious because
usually shonen manga are all about
stopping an evil force from reaching
world domination while in one piece this
has already happened centuries ago and
so the world of one piece is actually a
dystopia where a small group of inbred
and cruel nobles living on top of the
red line hold most of the wealth enslave
and kill people at will and brainwash
the population with propaganda and lies
all while the people on the sea below
live in poverty and despair and also in
fear of a culture of pirates that has
formed just because of these desperate
conditions what i love so much about
aichi roda the author of one piece is
how he somehow managed to hide this dark
and complex political foundation of the
story
under the mantle of the positive and fun
adventure that luffy and ko are on right
now
so even if you're someone who isn't
really interested in the politics of a
story you still know exactly what's
going on without even realizing it and
it makes the story enjoyable for a
younger shonen audience as well while
the deep and dark parts are still
clearly visible for the adults to me
this just once again shows what a
masterful writer oda sensei truly is in
a way you could argue that the fight of
the ancient kingdom versus what would
later become the world government was
the classic shonen setting luffy on the
other hand is a hero that doesn't just
have to stop the bad guys from winning
he has to change and liberate an entire
planet that has been ruled and
indoctrinated for almost 1 000 years
which to me makes things just much more
interesting because it's not enough to
just beat the big bad guy to keep
everything the way it is no luffy as the
hero has to actually present the world
with a system that works better than the
current one and i'm very curious how
people will react to the ideal system
oda has envisioned for the end of the
story because let's be honest no matter
what it is it's definitely gonna be
controversial similarly to how we all
kept wondering what political system the
end of game of thrones would bring with
it will the world of one piece have a
king complete anarchy in a pirate world
a democracy this will have a big impact
on all luffy is achieving right now so
who are these five men that rule the
world with an iron fist are they good or
evil how powerful are they and if they
truly are immortal how and what would it
mean for the story if they came from the
void century
in case you need a refresher the five
elders or gorosei as they're called in
japanese are a council of the most
highly ranked celestial dragons with
full control over the marines the cypher
pole agencies and even the seven
warlords of the sea while we know
neither their names nor their powers we
have seen them pulling the strings
behind almost everything happening all
over the world politically rivaled only
by the influence of the four emperors
that actually hold both the necessary
political and military power to deny the
world government and rule over the new
worlds now only quite recently have we
learned that the gorosei actually served
a mysterious figure called imu who rules
the world from the shadows
however while the elders obey his or her
orders it still very much seems like
most of the time they still have full
authority over the government's actions
now as you can imagine tyrannically
running an entire planet as a shadow
government can be an incredibly tiring
job if you have a similar problem to the
gorosei i got just the thing to sweeten
your day this awesome valentine-themed
snack box sent to me by boxu one of my
favorite sponsors actually boxu is a
monthly snack box subscription service
that delivers original assortments of
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
directly from japan to wherever you live
what i really like about this is that
they collaborate with traditional
japanese family manufacturers that make
these snacks and candies from scratch
and so you don't just get some random
stuff you can get in any japanese
supermarket but actual local stuff so
this is a really great opportunity i
think to experience some authentic
japanese food if you want to try that
for yourself go get your own boxus snack
box and get 10 off your first order
using my code and link in the
description below
okay back now to the dystopian oligarchy
of one piece so first of all why do i
think that the gorosei are very very
powerful in reality and will be actual
enemies that will have to be taken down
because i've seen a lot of opinions
stating that the gurus say are basically
glorified spandoms that's this guy in
case you forgot
the reason spandom was able to control
some of the government's most powerful
agents was not because he was smart
enough to manipulate them but because
they were ordered by the government in
other words the gorosei to help him now
you could say that the main source of
authority for the guru saying is that
they have both the marines and the
cyphapul agencies under their commands
however how exactly do they keep
authority over these groups after all
there is no higher power actually
backing them up well actually there is
but nobody knows about that if they
truly were just fandoms then surely in
the 800 year history of the government
some marine or government agent would
have tried to usurp them or heck even
the revolutionary army might have gone
straight for the heads when they
actually invaded marijuana a kainu out
of all people surely wouldn't have
listened to them if they didn't have
anything to back up their authority and
yet sengoku and akainu never think about
actually going against them at least so
far however i want you to notice just
how calm the gorosei are at zakazuki's
insolence
normally people would be trembling like
kobe had an andy sakazuki but the
gorosei simply shrug it off mocking him
and treating him like a tempered child
and honestly weaklings don't show this
type of confidence especially since
these five aren't stupid and then later
on we see them casually meeting with one
of the most powerful pirates in the
entire world dismissing their guards
no matter what powers they have at their
disposal the fact that they appear to
have battle experience and unwavering
authority over people like akainu and
luchi proves to me that they all must be
immensely physically powerful especially
after they realized that they could
subscribe to my channel for more weekly
one-piece content the big question i've
always asked myself is
how evil are these guys or are they evil
at all this is a truly interesting
question because i think other than
doflamingo for example the gorosei are
in a much more morally gray area on the
one hand they lead a regime that uses
slavery neglects and manipulates its
people and orders the destruction of an
entire island
[Applause]
but then oda sensei still throws in
nuances that make them appear more human
during the o'hara incident for instance
at least some of them seemed truly
pained with their decision they actually
wanted jinbei to create a better
relationship with the fishmen and
allowed them access to the referee and
they clearly were not happy with
doflamingo's actions but couldn't do
anything about it since he was a former
celestial dragon himself with knowledge
about the national treasure of marijuana
that he could have used as leverage
against them and out of all things they
seem to work with shanks to keep the
world in balance this gets even more
confusing when looking at oda senses
inspiration for all five of them what
just keeps fascinating me every time i
think about it is that all five of them
seem to be inspired by influential
historical political figures most
prominently there's this one who looks
like mahatma gandhi one of them looks
like a young abraham lincoln one like
karl marx one like mikhail gorbachev and
the one with the long beard like the
japanese politician itagaki taisuke now
all of these figures represent very
different political ideologies and all
of them had their obvious flaws but what
still unites all of them at least from a
historic perspective is that they all
are associated with giving people more
freedom
lincoln is known for ending slavery in
the us gandhi ended british colonial
rule in india marx's fundamental idea
that was later strongly misused by
multiple regimes was the theory of
liberty stating that the freedom of the
people is the most important right that
should not be exploited and controlled
by those with power and money gorbachev
was the last president of the soviet
union who with his ideas of glasnost and
perestroita openness and reconstructing
promoted democratic thinking and liberty
in eastern europe that ultimately led to
the collapse of the soviet union and
finally itagaki was the leader of the
freedom and people's rights movement and
involved with the founding of the very
first democratic political party in
japan so i don't know either hola sensei
is being very ironic by basing the
authoritarian rules of this world on
people fighting for freedom
or
there's something more to all of this to
me personally the main goal of the
government seems to be keeping the
balance of the worlds they met with
shanks they buy weapons from kaido and
they dealt with mother caramel for
powerful orphans
clearly they have no interest in getting
rid of the yonko system but rather
promote it there seem to be only two
instances where the government seems to
feel really threatened one was the
incident of o'hara that might have
revealed the true history of the world
and the other was emo's frustration with
luffy vv poseidon and blackbeard
[Music]
no kaido no big mom no dragon however
all of these four seem to have
connections to the void century except
blackbeard who seems to have connections
to rox who was also a major threat to
the government luffy's straw hat
connects him to the giant straw head on
marijua hirohoshi is an ancient weapon
and vivi is connected to pluton and the
only one of the 20 kingdoms that didn't
join the celestial dragons on the red
line as for shanks i don't think he's
plotting with the government but just
trying his best to ease the way for
luffy and keep the world from falling
apart before he even has the chance to
find the one piece so are the gorosei
just interested in keeping things as
they are and keep living in comfort
forever well they do seem to have a
fairly stressful job though i really
can't wait to find out what their
connection with emu truly is because i
think it would be a very interesting
twist indeed if one of them either imu
or the gorosei were actually a
quote-unquote good guy after all keeping
the other in check and from destroying
the world but let's talk about the
immortality thing there are actually a
number of theories out there that
connect emu and the gorosei to
immortality one option being of course
the ope opinomi that might have been
used multiple times another theory is
connected to the reoccurring theme of
flowers a golden flower that connected
emu and nika hand the lunarians i should
probably make just an entire video about
that idea in itself and the biggest
theory with the most evidence behind it
is this video right here where i explain
all the reasons why emo and the
celestial dragons are immortal and what
the secret behind that might actually be
you know if you're interested there
can't click it you don't have to you
might as well